Générique
...
-La recherche en santé publique
est essentielle
pour mieux comprendre
ce qui influence la santé.
Elle étudie, non pas les individus,
mais la population
dans son ensemble.
-On a besoin
de dizaines de milliers,
centaines de milliers
de personnes
et de beaucoup de données
collectées dans le temps.
-La recherche en santé publique
est donc un outil puissant
sur lequel baser
des politiques de prévention.
-La santé se construit
là où l'on naît, où l'on grandit,
où l'on vit, où l'on travaille,
et dès le plus jeune âge.
-Alors, comment faire
de cette recherche
un moteur
de l'action politique ?
A quoi sert la santé publique ?
C'est le thème
de ce numéro de "Etat de santé".
-Bonjour. Bienvenue.
On a tous une idée
de ce que c'est
que la recherche fondamentale,
avec les pipettes,
les ordis, les calculs,
qui trouve des médicaments,
qui soigne directement.
On connaît moins
la recherche en santé publique.
Or elle est partout,
C'est par exemple elle
qui a permis de nous faire savoir
que le tabac provoquait
le cancer du poumon.
C'est considérable.
Bonjour à vous, docteur.
-Bonjour.
-Merci d'être avec nous.
Vous êtes médecin
en santé publique,
Dr Karim Ould-Kaci.
On verra votre parcours,
dans un instant,
mais j'ai envie de vous demander :
pourquoi êtes-vous docteur
en santé publique ?
Vous ne voyez pas de malades.
Vous n'êtes plus clinicien.
-Non.
-Donc vous soignez quoi ?
-Je soigne des populations.
-Oui.
-J'ai toujours été passionné
par le fait politique en santé,
par la question des inégalités
de santé, depuis mon plus jeune âge,
donc je me suis orienté
dans des études de médecine
et dans une spécialisation
en santé publique.
-Vous êtes un oiseau rare
ou c'est très recherché ?
-Je suis un oiseau rare.
Il y a très peu de médecins
spécialistes en santé publique.
Votre question
n'est pas anodine.
C'est pas naturel, de s'orienter
vers la santé publique
quand on se lance
dans des études de médecine,
mais je fais partie
de ces personnes-là
qui peuvent être intéressées
par le fait politique
ou par les statistiques,
l'épidémiologie.
-On verra que la recherche
en santé publique est importante.
D'abord, votre portrait.
-Médecin de santé publique,
Karim Ould-Kaci est spécialisé
en organisation et gestion
des systèmes de santé.
Il a notamment travaillé
sur le suivi des patients
atteints du VIH
ou sur l'organisation
de l'offre hospitalière
au sein de l'ARS Picardie.
Il est aujourd'hui directeur
de la Fondation MGEN
pour la santé publique,
qui vise à apporter
une meilleure connaissance
de la santé des populations
et collabore avec des organismes
de recherche publique
tels que l'Inserm.
-Question définition :
"santé publique", c'est vague.
Qu'est-ce que c'est,
la recherche
en santé publique ?
-Il existe plein de définitions.
Je ne vais pas vous les citer,
mais une des choses qui caractérise
la santé publique, c'est :
on traite des populations,
cette approche populationnelle.
Ca, c'est une 1re chose
qui caractérise la santé publique.
La 2e chose qui est importante :
c'est plusieurs disciplines,
la santé publique.
C'est l'épidémiologie,
c'est les statistiques,
c'est l'informatique,
mais aussi l'économie.
-Quand on travaille
sur les épidémies,
- on en parlé récemment -
on fait de la santé publique ?
-Oui.
-On essaie de comprendre,
on compare,
on voit si le virus
qui amène une épidémie
est comparable à un autre,
allé sur un autre continent ?
C'est très concret.
C'est passionnant, de le décliner.
-C'est un exemple concret.
La santé publique,
ça permet d'observer,
d'observer les maladies,
d'observer les facteurs de risques
des maladies.
Ca permet aussi de surveiller,
surveiller les populations,
voir si des épidémies surviennent,
mais pas que.
On parle aussi
des risques environnementaux.
Autre exemple concret
de ce que peut être
la santé publique,
c'est le traitement
que vous prenez :
Est-il sûr ?
Marche-t-il ?
La santé publique permet de répondre
à ces questions.
-C'est considérable.
Infographie : regardez-la
pour achever ces questions
de définition.
-Est-ce que le tabac provoque
le cancer du poumon ?
Faut-il se méfier des pilules
de troisième génération ?
Comment mieux prendre en charge
la perte d'autonomie ?
La chirurgie ambulatoire
donne-t-elle
de meilleurs résultats ?
Autant de questions qui ont
un point commun :
la recherche
en santé publique.
Que se cache-t-il
derrière ce terme très vaste ?
Pour résumer, c'est comprendre
l'influence des facteurs
qui déterminent
la santé des populations
et proposer des actions
et des politiques de santé
fondées sur ces connaissances.
L'un des enjeux importants
est de répondre aux inégalités.
Sociales ou territoriales,
elles pèsent fortement
sur la santé.
Or, selon la DREES,
la France serait le pays d'Europe
où ces inégalités seraient
les plus fortes.
Exemple : l'espérance de vie
en bonne santé.
Elle est de 69 ans pour un cadre
et de 59 pour un ouvrier.
Et ça commence
dès l'école maternelle.
13 % des enfants d'ouvriers seraient
en surcharge pondérale
contre 8 %
pour les enfants de cadres.
Comprendre ces inégalités
et comment les réduire
est donc indispensable
pour créer
des politiques de prévention
efficaces
et c'est tout l'enjeu
de la recherche en santé publique.
-Dans les questions aussi
de définition :
qui fait
de la santé publique ?
Est-ce que, comme son nom l'indique,
il n'y a que le secteur public
ou le secteur privé
s'empare aussi de ces enjeux ?
-C'est une excellente question.
Souvent, on pense que
santé publique = public.
En fait, santé publique
veut dire population.
Et les acteurs privés interviennent
en santé publique.
Certes, il y a les organismes
publics de recherche,
mais il y a aussi des fondations,
des associations.
Vous avez les industriels.
L'industrie pharmaceutique,
lorsqu'ils font
des essais thérapeutiques,
d'une certaine manière,
utilisent les paradigmes
de la santé publique.
Pour rebondir,
les médecins spécialistes
de santé publique
n'en ont pas le monopole.
C'est ce que j'évoquais,
il y a plein de disciplines :
de l'économie, de la sociologie,
des sciences politiques,
de la géographie,
des statistiques...
C'est autant
de spécialistes qui peuvent
contribuer à la santé publique.
-C'est passionnant.
Justement,
Alexia Léperon s'est interrogée
ou plutôt est allée à la rencontre
de ces chercheurs en santé publique
qui travaillent sur
ou avec un outil,
- on connaît ce nom,
mais on voit pas toujours
ce que ça recouvre -
qui est la cohorte.
La cohorte,
c'est, encore une fois,
un levier très intéressant
de santé publique,
et notamment
l'une des plus anciennes cohortes.
On va voir ce que c'est,
c'est intéressant.
Elle s'appelle
E3N-Générations.
On regarde le reportage
et on se retrouve après.
-C'était il y a
un peu plus de 30 ans.
-Je sais pas,
là, j'avais peut-être...
45 ans, je pense.
-En 1990,
Michelle est invitée à participer
à une grande étude
de santé publique :
l'étude E3N.
-Tout de suite, je me suis dit :
"Ah, ben au moins,
"c'est quelque chose de concret."
Je me suis dit que de toute façon,
ça ne pouvait être qu'utile.
C'était des renseignements fiables
pour de la recherche.
-Aujourd'hui, à 75 ans,
Michelle est toujours très investie
dans l'étude.
Tous les deux ans environ,
elle reçoit
un questionnaire à remplir.
-Alors, les boissons chaudes.
"Volume du contenu représenté."
-Alimentation, mode de vie,
exercice physique,
vie quotidienne
et même sentiments,
tout est passé au crible
avec une grande précision.
-Si on veut être précis,
il y a des mesures à prendre,
donc par moments, le questionnaire,
c'est un peu lourd.
"Lourd", c'est peut-être exagéré.
C'est un peu pénible.
Mais d'un autre côté,
c'est vrai que vous vous dites :
"Il doit pas y avoir
tant de monde que ça
"qui le remplit soigneusement,
"qui le renvoie
ou qui peut encore le remplir."
-Une tâche parfois rébarbative,
mais pourtant essentielle.
C'est ici que le questionnaire
est traité et réceptionné.
Comme Michelle,
100 000 femmes ont été recrutées
pour participer à l'étude E3N.
On appelle ça une cohorte.
Leurs réponses sont stockées
dans ce sous-sol
de l'institut Gustave Roussy.
Ces archives sont une fierté
pour Gianluca Severi,
coordinateur de la cohorte.
-Plus d'un million
de questionnaires,
des informations énormes,
riches,
grâce à l'engagement
de ces femmes,
c'est assez extraordinaire.
-Ces réponses sont aussi précieuses,
car elles permettent
aux chercheurs d'en savoir plus
sur l'apparition de maladies.
-Pour avoir
une puissance statistique
et déterminer certains liens
entre les facteurs de risques
et les maladies,
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin
de dizaines de milliers,
centaines de milliers de personnes
et de beaucoup de données
collectées dans le temps.
-Au cours de ces 30 ans,
la cohorte E3N a permis
de mener des centaines d'études.
C'est en particulier
dans la prévention du cancer,
et notamment ses liens
avec l'alimentation,
que les recherches ont permis
de grandes avancées.
Et dans ce domaine,
les questionnaires ne sont pas
les seuls outils des chercheurs.
Ce bâtiment abrite
l'autre grande richesse
de la cohorte E3N : une biobanque.
Cette chercheuse travaille
dans l'équipe de Gianluca Severi.
-C'est ici qu'on stocke
l'échantillon E3N.
-OK.
-Prélevés dans les années 90,
25 000 échantillons de sang
sont stockés ici
et toujours utilisés
par les chercheurs.
Francesca Mancini y a trouvé
la présence de certaines
substances chimiques toxiques
qu'on retrouve dans l'alimentation :
les PFAS.
Selon cette étude,
il pourrait y avoir un lien
avec le cancer du sein.
-On a pu comparer
les niveaux d'exposition,
donc les niveaux de présence
de cette substance dans le sang
avant le développement du cancer
et évaluer la potentielle
association de cette exposition
avec le risque
de développer le cancer du sein.
Les résultats nous suggèrent
qu'en fait, il y a
une association positive
entre l'exposition à ces substances
et le risque de développer
le cancer du sein,
mais surtout un risque
de développer le cancer du sein
qu'on peut définir
comme hormono-sensible.
-Pour aller encore plus loin
dans la recherche,
la cohorte s'est élargie
il y a quelques années
en intégrant les enfants
des premières participantes,
leurs conjoints, puis récemment,
leurs petits-enfants.
Cet aspect familial ouvre
de vastes possibilités
pour la science
et pour l'étude
de Francesca Mancini.
-Nous, notre avantage,
c'est qu'on a la deuxième génération
qui sera déjà adulte au moment
où on rentre dans notre étude,
donc ça nous permettra d'étudier
les relations
entre les comportements de la mère
et les risques de développer
certaines pathologies à l'âge adulte
de leurs enfants.
-Avec aujourd'hui 12 700 familles
suivies sur deux générations,
la cohorte E3N-Générations souhaite
rassembler au total
200 000 participants.
Une nouvelle collecte
d'échantillons sanguins est prévue
afin de poursuivre l'étude.
-Alors vous connaissez bien
cette cohorte.
Ca fait 30 ans qu'elle existe.
C'est considérable, 30 ans.
-C'est un exploit, en effet.
Le sens même des cohortes,
c'est leur longévité.
-Pas le volume. C'est le temps.
-Vous avez raison, c'est les deux :
le temps et le volume.
Plus on a de données,
plus elles sont sur un temps long
et plus on peut creuser
de problématiques.
C'est une cohorte
assez exceptionnelle.
Le fait de voir
que des personnes sont motivées
à continuer à répondre aux questions
30 ans après, c'est exceptionnel.
-C'est fascinant.
-Oui.
-C'est facile à trouver,
des volontaires ?
-Non, c'est très difficile.
Je dois avouer que,
concernant cette cohorte,
il y a une particularité
sociologique, si je puis dire,
car elle a été constituée
à partir de femmes enseignantes,
et on sait que les enseignants
d'une manière générale
sont plus sensibles
aux problématiques de la recherche
que le reste de la population.
-Dr Ould-Kaci,
est-ce que les grandes épidémies,
- je pense au VIH dans les années 80
ou au Covid,
plus près de nous -
ce sont des accélérateurs
en termes de recherches
de santé publique ?
-Oui, c'est un accélérateur
considérable,
notamment l'épidémie
du VIH, et je dirais un des leviers,
un des facteurs
explicatifs, c'est :
dans quelle mesure
est-ce que les citoyens,
le débat public,
se saisit de ces problématiques ?
Et c'est par le débat public,
par les citoyens,
que le renouveau
de la santé publique intervient,
et de la même manière, le VIH a été
un changement de paradigme.
Je pense que le Covid sera aussi
-Parfois, la recherche
en santé publique,
elle est là
où on ne l'attend pas.
C'est le sujet du reportage
d'Alexia Léperon,
qui est allée voir comment
des chercheurs
s'appuient
sur des interventions
très concrètes.
Ca s'appelle la recherche
interventionnelle.
Elle a suivi une chercheuse
qui étudie l'impact
de la végétalisation
des cours
d'école sur la santé, à Bordeaux.
Reportage.
-Quand on pense à la recherche
scientifique, voici le genre d'image
qu'on a en tête.
Mais en santé publique,
ça peut parfois ressembler à ça :
étudier le terrain.
Linda Cambon est chercheuse.
Son travail :
comprendre comment l'environnement
agit sur la santé des enfants.
-La santé, elle se construit
là où on naît,
où l'on grandit, où l'on vit,
où l'on travaille.
Et elle se construit
dès le plus jeune âge.
C'est-à-dire que ce que l'enfant
va traverser d'environnement
va avoir un impact majeur
sur son développement
et sur sa santé. C'est un public
qui est vraiment privilégié,
en matière de santé publique.
C'est un public prioritaire.
-Concrètement,
pour mener cette recherche,
elle s'appuie
sur une action entamée
par la ville de Bordeaux,
qui a végétalisé les cours d'école
pour les rendre plus agréables.
Ce jour-là, l'élue à l'origine
du projet vient lui présenter
la cour de l'école Jacques-Prévert.
-Bonjour, Linda.
Ravie de vous accueillir
dans notre belle cour.
-Magnifique.
-Nous sommes convaincus
que ce projet permet...
généralement,
un meilleur épanouissement
de l'enfant.
Donc c'est vraiment le respect
du rythme de l'enfant, disons,
où on va avoir un coin calme
où ils peuvent venir
avec un bouquin,
d'autres, s'ils veulent
faire des jeux,
ils pourront le faire...
-Ca, c'est ce qu'a imaginé
la mairie.
A partir de là,
la chercheuse
souhaite étudier s'il y a bien
un impact de cette action
sur la bonne santé des enfants,
et dans quelles conditions.
Cette démarche est appelée
"recherche interventionnelle".
-Une des spécificités
de la recherche interventionnelle,
c'est de produire des conclusions
circonstanciées
là où la recherche traditionnelle
va en produire, comme on dit,
"toute chose étant égale
par ailleurs", hors contexte.
On observe que ça ne peut pas
se déployer après, sur le terrain.
On n'a pas pris en compte
ce contexte et son influence.
Du coup, la recherche
interventionnelle
prend en compte ce contexte
et va analyser son effet.
Ca nécessite de partir
d'expérimentations de terrain.
-Sauf que, justement,
sur le terrain,
Linda se rend compte
que la nouvelle cour de récré
ne fait pas forcément
l'unanimité.
-Bonjour, les enfants.
-BONJOUR.
-J'aurais envie de savoir
ce que vous pensez
de cette cour d'école.
-Euh...
-Bien.
-Elle est...
Elle est bien,
mais y a des points positifs
et des points
négatifs.
-C'est mieux
parce qu'il y a plus
de végétation,
mais on a beaucoup moins la place,
avec les bancs....
-Ils ont enlevé beaucoup d'espace.
-Il faut se laisser la possibilité
de pas entendre
ce qu'on a forcément
envie d'entendre.
On n'est pas dans une stratégie
confirmatoire d'hypothèse.
On essaie de comprendre,
vraiment.
Et donc, il faut... se laisser
surprendre par le terrain,
essayer de creuser,
comment ils vivent
cet espace-là,
est-ce que ça leur fait du bien,
est-ce qu'ils regrettent
la cour d'avant, qu'y aurait-il
à modifier ?
Et on voit qu'il ressort des choses
qui pourraient être vues autrement,
parce que ça a été pensé,
dans la concrétisation,
par un adulte,
et eux, ça peut les gêner,
cet espace-là peut les gêner,
ou ils auraient envie
de l'investir différemment.
Donc c'est ça que je vais essayer
de comprendre
pour avoir des recommandations,
aussi, d'aménagement.
Enlever les barrières,
avoir plus
d'espace, pas de copeaux,
et plus d'espaces comme ça,
pour pouvoir courir ?
-Oui !
-Avant d'avoir les 1ers résultats,
Linda et son équipe
devront encore interroger
et observer régulièrement
tous les acteurs concernés
par le projet.
Un travail assez long,
qui peut être un frein
au développement
de ce type de recherche.
Au CHU de Bordeaux,
le professeur François Alla dirige
le service qui porte cette étude.
Il déplore le manque d'ampleur
de la recherche interventionnelle
en France.
-On travaille pas sur une politique
comme sur un médicament,
pour faire un parallèle.
Donc effectivement,
c'est de la recherche complexe,
qui nécessite du temps,
beaucoup d'investissement humain,
beaucoup de discipline
et de compétences différentes.
C'est difficile
de la mettre en oeuvre,
particulièrement en France
où elle est peu soutenue,
institutionnellement.
-En France,
la recherche interventionnelle
représente moins de 1 %
des financements
accordés à la recherche publique
en santé.
Son développement
pourrait pourtant participer
à établir de meilleures politiques
de prévention.
-Dr Ould-Kaci,
la recherche interventionnelle,
j'y reviens, qu'est-ce qu'elle a
de spécifique, dans le fond ?
-Sa particularité,
c'est d'aider à faire face
à une des grandes limites
de notre système de santé
qui est les inégalités de santé.
On a de grosses inégalités de santé
en France.
Je peux vous donner deux chiffres,
deux exemples.
Il y a une différence de 13 ans
d'espérance de vie,
chez les hommes,
entre les 5 % les plus riches
de notre population
et les 5 % les plus défavorisés.
Un autre exemple,
c'est que la probabilité
de mourir à âge égal,
ça peut être le double
entre deux personnes qui habitent
à quelques kilomètres seulement.
La recherche interventionnelle
est un des outils
permettant de lutter
contre ces inégalités.
-Par exemple, ça, c'est relatif
aux conditions de travail ?
-Oui.
-On en a parlé.
Mais c'est pas un domaine
de la santé publique.
-Ce n'est pas le domaine
de la médecine,
mais c'est celui
de la santé publique.
Le domaine de la santé publique,
par définition, est plurisectoriel.
On parle de déterminants de santé,
c'est du jargon, mais ça veut dire :
"Qu'est-ce qui
"influe sur la santé ?"
-L'environnement,
la génétique, la naissance...
On a tellement de facteurs !
-Enormément, oui.
Tout.
Tout est dans la santé,
en fait.
La recherche interventionnelle
permet, d'une certaine manière,
d'aller s'attaquer
aux déterminants sociaux,
donc la composante sociale
de la santé.
-On profite de cette émission
pour interpeller un député
sur une question
qui vous tient à coeur.
En l'occurrence,
Cyrille Isaac-Sibille du MoDem.
Vous lui avez demandé comment
adopter une démarche de santé
dans les différentes
politiques publiques.
Voici sa réponse.
-La problématique actuelle,
c'est que le système de santé
est tourné vers le système de soins.
Alors que, comme on le disait,
effectivement, le soin ne joue
que pour 20-25 % de l'amélioration
de notre santé,
et que le but, évidemment,
c'est d'améliorer la prévention.
L'assurance maladie,
c'est une promesse qu'on a faite
aux Français.
"Si vous êtes malade,
on prendra en charge les soins."
Maintenant, il faut faire
une nouvelle promesse aux Français,
c'est-à-dire : on va favoriser
les bons comportements de santé
et donc, la promesse
qu'on doit faire actuellement,
c'est de parler de la prévention
et des bons comportements
et du bon environnement
pour la santé,
de manière globale, qui touche
l'ensemble des politiques.
-Dr Ould-Kaci,
vous me disiez :
la santé publique est partout.
On a parlé du monde du travail...
la santé, en fait...
Elle est partout, la santé.
Donc ça a un sens de limiter
le champ de la santé publique
au ministère de la Santé ?
-C'est une vraie question de fond
que bien des chercheurs se posent.
Certains recommandent que la santé
soit intégrée dans une forme
de comité
interministériel.
Il y a déjà ce genre de comité
qui ont été mis en place,
mais vraiment de pousser la logique
et de faire en sorte, finalement,
qu'on évalue l'impact
des politiques publiques
dans le monde
de la santé
avant de les lancer.
-Pour conclure, docteur,
si je vous demande comme ça,
à brûle-pourpoint,
une belle étude
dont la recherche en santé publique
peut être fière, en France,
qu'est-ce qui vous vient
à l'esprit ?
-Il y a une étude,
en santé publique,
qui va peut-être illustrer
ce que j'évoque,
qui a étudié les 30 ans
de gain d'espérance de vie
au siècle dernier.
Et cette étude conclue
que 25 % des 30 ans
d'espérance de vie gagnés
sont liés au système de santé
en tant que tel.
Ca veut dire quoi ?
Ca veut dire que le reste,
l'immense majorité,
près de 75 %, du reste des 30 ans
d'espérance de vie gagnés
sont le fait de choses
qui sont en-dehors
du système de santé.
-C'est-à-dire ?
-Les comportements,
l'amélioration des conditions
de vie, vous avez parlé
des conditions de vie au travail...
-L'alimentation ?
-L'alimentation,
l'activité physique,
en effet.
-Ca, par exemple, la santé publique,
elle nous a indiqué des choses
très précises sur l'impact
de l'activité physique sur la santé.
-Exact.
-Tout ça, pourquoi on le fait
et pourquoi des politiques
sont mises en oeuvre,
c'est parce que la santé publique
détermine ce type de... déterminants
-Exactement.
C'est la santé publique
qui a montré
que défaut d'activité
physique et sédentarité
sont des facteurs de risques
de cancers, de maladies
cardio-vasculaires.
C'est la santé publique, aussi,
qui détermine
quelles sont les politiques
les plus efficaces
pour faire en sorte qu'on suive
les recommandations en matière
d'activité physique.
Vous le disiez, la santé publique,
elle est partout.
-C'est passionnant.
Merci, docteur,
d'avoir été avec nous
dans "Etat de santé".
Merci de nous avoir suivis
et à très vite sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...